[Music]
so baby's gonna be talking about the
same thing what are you talking about
and then you lead me over to this I
think this area right here
no and and I'll just know they do it a
few men okay look I'm me yeah and you're
my lady
nothing okay that's good that's good
gonna be as athletic as it is erotic
okay here we go
so you're the man I'm your lady and then
you just get down what do you want me to
do on me okay
and you're my lady okay so we'll start
out with some I'll do some crunches and
what do you want me to do this will push
up to my knees right here yeah okay you
sure you're anchored you're not gonna
get hurt I'm fine okay hold it I'll
throw this all the time okay here we go
Eddie very erotic ready go go today
mmm we should meet meet you know family
right there right there yes your honor
you'll be right in here and we're small
talk that was funny it was small talk
yeah yeah I got to get really in there
get in there good
[Music]
yeah yeah middle Turks down now all the
way down right
don't start cheating you're not cheating
me you cheating you're cheating yourself
out this is pretty cool too okay
back-to-back yeah this is a stretching
more that's just an exercise so pull me
back I go forward okay today this one
may look less erotic though it certainly
feel it less erotic now what do you want
to do next
oops now tip-top okay so where am i
doing I'm front what no turn around turn
around
okay right here yeah all right all right
hugs workmen doing baby area no talking
lady why you doing all you small talker
how's work been it's been good how's
that [ __ ] Karen give me your heart song
I hate that [ __ ] Hey see that no one
likes
[Music]